he's the CEO Dollar Shave Club and he's
Mike Dubin Mike big news as Dollar Shave
Club sold for a billion dollars and just
like to say we did it we we made this
happen Mike yet the checks on its way
like we're gonna or we contended nickels
and dimes what do you prefer uh whatever
whatever makes you happy I mean you're
you're a partner we did it together and
we made America proud we made America
great today we did and you know I just I
want to say from a young age my parents
impressed on me the values that you work
hard for what you want in life it's your
word is your bond and that you do what
you say you keep your promise and you
treat people with respect right do
anything to keep going no you get you
got it you got it i'm sure you
plagiarize that from somebody but you
sound you sound great and honest and
doing that okay now when the concept
began like take us back to the beginning
days embryonic stages of this with
Dollar Shave Club well yeah I mean look
I started it in my apartment and it was
it wasn't exactly something that I
thought would get to where we are today
and you know we I set out to solve a
problem that guys were having and doing
the fun way and just take it one step at
a time but you know we you know I I
could never say that I I thought this is
where we would get to did it almost no
one happen many times absolutely I mean
there were so many things that you know
that almost went wrong it could have
gone wrong it did go wrong there were
there were many people that told me that
this is a ridiculous idea to try to take
on you know one of the world's most
formidable functional monopolies in the
space and and that I should I should I
should try something else but that's
that's anybody that started a business
they always tell you and they always
tell you that that your idea is no good
and that's why that's why they're not
doing it and you are but you're staying
one sort of like Dana White is with UFC
that you're still going to stay on with
Dollar Shave Club oh yeah absolutely you
know this is this is absolutely not at
all you know the end of the journey in
fact it's it's just the beginning of the
next chapter which I'm super-excited for
and I wouldn't have you know we weren't
out in the market looking for a buyer
and you know I met I met the president
of Unilever North America edit dinner
and we hit it off we built a lot of
trust and the conversation really
started around one as an advisory role
or or even an investment in Dollar Shave
Club but as as we got to know more about
the organization and how they can help
us do what we're trying to do I got more
excited about working with these guys
and and so they made us an offer that
that we couldn't refuse in and and here
we are but I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have done the deal if if we if we didn't
have the chance to you know be run
independently and I and I would stay on
as a CEO and and you know that's awesome
will your commercials reflect a
different you definitely not definitely
not so you're going to still appeal you
have to appeal to every man so it's not
like you're going to be on a yacht sympa
sipping champagne in the South of France
you know that you're or you could spoof
it if you wanted to yeah yeah we can
have we can that's the beauty of this of
this deal is that we can still do
whatever we want to do which is exactly
what we've been doing and you know we're
having the best time doing it mclovin
says that you guys were best friends at
Sports Illustrated you did brooch him
with the idea of maybe investing in is
that right mclovin well I don't even
know if Michael remembers we were
co-workers at Sports Illustrated i was
on the editorial side do you remember
mclovin Mike how i do i do it was acted
was it the last round one yeah I was the
water cooler and I said you know I just
think people are not gonna want to break
from tradition when it comes to
something like shaving and he said well
you're probably right but I'll try
anyway yeah is that how it went down
like more or less more like I invested
in cattle instead he doesn't really work
it
work you and very offensive pork not in
Dollar Shave Club well congrats it's a
it's a great story and having been there
to the offices and seeing your staff I
can understand why you put forth a great
product they're great people there and I
wish you the best of luck and continue
to support this program we appreciate
them oh yeah well thank you guys for
other you've done over the years you
guys been a great friend to the company
and you know we'll we'll look forward to
continuing that relationship for a long
time thank you Mike it's Mike Dubin the
CEO of dollar shave club just sold for a
billion dollars the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience